mmm one units of measurement one of the
things that would come and so far I'm
doing this kind of like a clock so let's
start at 12 what was the very first
thing we looked at I've given you some
perform initials was the very first
thing we looked at it this time see Ulya
figures now this made sense right yeah
this maintains what you're thinking
about the measurement the first issue
that sort of slaps you in the face is
that as soon as you are measuring
something right you have accuracy when
it's like well what kind of accuracy do
I have so we talked about significant
figures as well this is the amount of
accuracy that's appropriate but a
measurement that I've taken okay from
significant fears where do we move
forward to Thank You scientific notation
and these make sense to put together
because not only do you encounter like
how much detail do I really have but
when you have big numbers and you have
large numbers you're going to have all
these rounded of zeroes right do we
really need to include this isn't there
a more efficient way do we go the other
way isn't there a more efficient way of
writing these know at the scientific
attention so much we're done right then
where do we go after them remember we're
still about negative things right okay
so we looked at the metric system for
all of these units right and we also
look at the fact well if you've got lots
of units or really really small parts of
units then we use prefixes to make
things big or small like kilo and mega
and senti or merely or nano or whatever
ok so again we're still very clearly in
measurement land and then we said well
you remember when we talked about using
physical instruments right it's not just
problems of accuracy but what if you
just read it wrong what do you read it
wrong you're like oh it's within this
range so the next thing we looked at was
arrows right and that's one of things we
looked at in this quiz we want to
account for the fact that you never
really hundred percent done okay but you
can know you're within a range if it's
actually enough for you that's efficient
now the last two concepts i looked at
most recently started with
ah ratios now this is when deliberation
we did rates first actually I'll just
leave that where it is when you've got
more than one quantity right and you're
trained to now make in comparison
between these two ratios and rates are
both about multiple quantities what's
the difference between a ratio and a
rape yeah yep perfect or you know the
money devil that we just did right it's
like this person is going to get dollars
and this professors gonna get more
dollars and even more dollars but
they're all currency yeah so that's what
ratios about and rates differ because
they are ya differ use like km/h or
looks per dollar whatever it is right
now that just leaves two ideas here the
first one we get a look at this lesson
is percentage change that's why the
heading is there okay now how does this
connect with all of these ideas we've
already mentioned if you come back to
this arm ratios idea right you might
compare say okay let me compare saying
my height to garrison the groomers okay
so there's two different things but
maybe the thing we want to compare is
actually say Gary site now versus Gary
type five years ago or Gary site in five
years or whatever it is okay so in other
words it's not like there's two separate
ideas it's one idea but is changed over
time and that's what I'm going to
compare so that's what this is about I'm
going to leave that last bottle there
empty it will fill it every next group
some people you dash off the ancient but
now we're ready to start me look at this
and it's not a complicated idea so
presented shake here's a typical
question that you might receive errors
have a look at a couple ways of doing
this because you've seen questions like
this before okay here's method number
one and it's going to be a bit longer
but it'll build it'll show us how about
the two months if you're increasing your
number by a certain percentage a natural
first thing to do is work out warm what
is that change what's the amount that
[Music]
I'm going to get bigger by okay what is
thirteen percent of 210
nothing populated it now okay before we
get to that number right thirty percent
of 210 is thirty percent x 210 right
just that we follow that so hahaha
that's hilarious oh that's all okay so
let's try this again someone was a bit
overzealous with your wife Ibaka okay so
let's try thirteen percent shall we um
if we have that exists all 200 like if
we're going to go from calculus now look
if you said it's okay actually right so
this is the event that I go octopi okay
so the actual thing that I'll end up
with it therefore I guess I take the
total is the original you started with
floss the increase right 210 Plus that
increase that we just calculated change
so what's that 230 7.3 done okay so
that's not complicated but we see we've
done two steps here when really we could
do vote right we could have gotten
straight to this 237 number directly in
a single line right do you notice come
on we've worked out thirty percent of
210 and then what we added to do was a
hundred percent of 210 because that's
where you started right so if i do in
thirteen percent over a hundred percent
i can just do this in one hit and you
might remember these from fm2 or
investing right I could say our total
equals 210 and I'm a little x the one
over two percent and thirteen percent
together all in one hundred one hundred
ninety percent of course right there's
the original note and then there's the
increase and when you push that into
your calculator you might like to put in
1.13 instead of one hundred thirteen
percent they're both fine and you will
save a single key press ok you go to get
number out can someone just verify that
we're going to get the same result yeah
thumbs up okay so
you can see this is clearly a more
efficient way and what's really nice
about it is remember I said hey this is
kind of a reminding me of denisof not
good this is reminding me of this number
in FM two we learned about these guys
right and you can see let me scroll up a
little before you do you see this guy
here right this is exactly what's
happening here it's just kind of is
algebra there see that one plus are you
don't need to write down but if you will
help you in my baby one is just a fancy
way of writing 100 over 100 which is
itself a fancy way of writing one
hundred percent because that's what
percent means right out of 100 and then
what's this guy here or in our case it
was thirteen percent or whatever rate
you like right so there's your 100% this
you're thirteen percent so that's
exactly what this formula is doing ok so
we've met this idea before not so crazy
let's do what mathematicians love to do
and I'm try and make a rule out of this
right so that I don't have to work this
out from scratch every single time so if
you have another color right another
color as rule you go to any amount you
want right let's call it hey as it
and you want to increase it if you're a
to increase it by say well any dissent
you choose so better than any number i'm
just going to call it X as we have a as
an about it could be dollars or numbers
or oranges and weight apply to increase
it by some percentage we can write have
a look at the way we did this have a
look at the second approach which comes
with the first one and more the order to
a single step you've got that amount
that you began with in our case is 210 a
and then we multiplied it by what what
we put in here where did this 130 number
come from again it's a hundred plus yeah
in a case of 13 but here are my gear for
anything for anything you like a hundred
plus let's call it X right % okay so you
can put a box around that this is how to
do percentage increase in just the same
way I don't think we need an example
right if I changed everything to
decrease suppose I wanted to decrease
200 turn five thirteen percent what
would be different yeah so instead of
our cool here's the amount let's add it
i'm going to say here's the amount let's
subtract right so this would turn into a
minus sign which would mean it down here
instead of a hundred and thirty one
hundred plus 13 what would this number
babies it's going to be 87 because it'd
be 100 take away 13 and that would give
me that the number i'm after okay so if
you want um just like this if you have
another column if you change this to
decrease your decreased by an X percent
instead of increase the early difference
here will be a times what's in the
brackets 100 month
yeah I have you take malaria now what's
really important is the you don't fixate
on visas rules these are shortcuts to
save us time but this is where they come
from I can use these whenever I like I'm
also just to finish before I get you
started and you'll notice I've always
ninja type the questions that you do
this idea of like what if it decreases
is something we're going to look at a
whole lot when we talk about this I
don't know how many of you have heard of
depreciation before depreciation is the
opposite of compound interest
competitors which speak bigger and
bigger and value depreciations wear
something shrinks in them right like if
you buy a car it followed damaged so
it's worth less and less see that see
that there that one minus R what it
really is is a hundred percent take away
opposite it's the same formula